so now it's time for our wednesday draft
mvp candidates very simple but very
complicated there's a lot of guys out
there how do we rank them we're going to
draft them one after another chris i
guess you have the trivia question i do
here we go cordell patterson as you know
he returned to kick off return for a
touchdown last week against the new
orleans saints it was his seventh career
kickoff return for td
only two players in nfl history have
returned more kickoffs for touchdowns
than cordell patterson who are they mike
florio
i have to name both just one it's not
just name one one's good devin hester
really sorry leon washington or josh
cribbs okay
i know listen these questions yes are
bullcrap right all right when it's the
question for me and i'm talking to you
in the control room and you know who
specifically i'm talking to in the
control room quit giving me the hard
questions how am i supposed to know leon
washington are you kidding me the guy
hasn't played in 15 years what about all
right make the first pick he was
legitimately actually josh chris
i mean legitimately really but really
that is such an esoteric question with
no obvious hook i mean come on how do
you expect me to know that off the top
of my head yeah well maybe
just read the history books i would have
got it right i knew both of them so i
mean sure sure you would have all right
go ahead oh the aaron rodgers you will
be my first pick today in this draft
yes i'm going with aaron rodgers this is
a close one here at the top of the list
right now but i'm going to go with aaron
rodgers because i think he persona
personifies mvp to what we've seen at
this point yeah i don't think they're
sitting here at six and one unless they
have aaron rodgers at quarterback uh one
his ability to kind of just make a few
plays early on when the offense wasn't
very good even though the stats weren't
good you know it was a handful of plays
that got them over the edges and all
those games and now we've seen the
offense and him all kind of cohesively
come together and without big time
talent and a lot of receivers that most
people can't name i mean he's starting
to put on a show on a weekly basis now
and this just shows you when aaron
rodgers has a system which he has not
had the last few years how dangerous he
can be no matter who's playing around
him uh but i think right now yes aaron
rodgers would be my leader in the
clubhouse as far as the mvp race is
concerned but very very close with some
other guys
here's the thing though i made the
argument last week for the first time
that aaron rodgers should get mvp
consideration people thought i was crazy
what has one week changed
i was in that convert i was with you in
that i was so proud of you that you made
it a public thing because i think within
you making it a public thing there was a
lot of people in the football world that
were thinking that but i think you made
it and
unleash it to the masses and then people
got to see again what he did on sunday
and i think it helped everybody connect
more dots to go you know what it has
been pretty damn good despite maybe the
stats haven't been you know amazing so
thank you for doing that for me and for
aaron that's very nice to you the stats
were definitely there on sunday career
game yeah and i just it feels weird
saying that but career game literally
for aaron rodgers all right you're going
to give me lamar jackson i'm going to
take lamar jackson
top of the stack right now he out
russell wilson russell wilson in his own
home i mean russell wilson was the the
top guy last week lamar jackson came in
and took it from him and look the
passing numbers on sunday weren't
spectacular but for this season he's
averaging 235 passing yards per game
that's more than guys like jacoby
brissett and jimmy garoppolo and he's
he's he's sixth in rushing sixth in
rushing in the entire national football
league a great two-way threat he's
becoming the guy that he was at
louisville when he won the heisman and
actually he was better the year after he
won the heisman louisville the team just
wasn't very good so he didn't get real
consideration but this is a special year
so far for lamar jackson my concern is
can he stay healthy if he can stay
healthy and if he can keep this up and
the ravens can continue to run the afc
north he's going to be getting votes
when mvp time comes around yes uh
this is who i struggled with it would
have been him or rogers i think right
now or maybe the next guy i'm gonna pick
but i do think that again lamar jackson
he is the mvp of that team and certainly
in the running for everything he's doing
for that team and and making them
relevant and his skill set is special uh
and he's explosive and man he's one of
the most dangerous runners in football
in the open field okay i go to my next
guy i'm going to the guy you just talked
about i mean yeah baltimore out seattle
seattle in seattle and you don't see
that a whole lot okay that's the saying
that's how you go it right there but
russell wilson
uh will be my next pick still russell
wilson is a phenomenal year yes last
week was bad i get it it wasn't perfect
uh he made it through a big pick six and
a big moment uh that certainly sw you
know swung the pendulum to the favor of
the baltimore ravens like how i used
that word correctly there but but um
russell wilson i think again just like
the other two guys we've talked about
is
one of the few guys in football that
could really make it work up there in
seattle yes they run the football well
but their defense isn't as great as it's
been in years past they let up big plays
uh and their offense is the one that i
don't look at the passing offense and go
oh wow this is some of the most
game-breaking
passing schemes i've ever seen they have
a little bit of everything but they're
not exactly blowing my mind with
imagination a lot of it happens because
of russell wilson's ability to extend
plays like we're watching here or make
unbelievable runs or throws i mean
that's one of the damnedest throws we've
seen ever i mean that was unreal so
russell wilson will be my second pick
yeah i think that's a good pick by you
although he lost some of that yeah he
lost some steam he did yeah that picked
six hertz and you know he had those
great numbers his passer rating actually
fell below kirk cousins
after that performance on sunday where
his passer rating went from the the 120s
down into the one teams because he had a
65 but still he's in the conversation
i'm gonna go christian mccaffrey here
i'm torn between him and desean watson
and if the texans had beaten the colts
on sunday i would have gone to sean
watson i'm going christian mccaffrey
he's not still on pace to set the single
season yards from scrimmage record he's
a little bit off of it he's had that bye
week so we've kind of forgotten about
him a little bit but he is the mvp of
the panthers right now and he could be
the mvp of the league if they keep
pushing in the direction that they are
going and they keep winning games
without cam newton you have to take
christian mccaffrey seriously the key
for him just like with lamar jackson
staying healthy because he is reckless
with his body he stays away from big
injury but man he's just looked banged
up in a few games but he finds a way to
keep going and if he keeps going and
plays all 16 games he's going to have
some eye-popping numbers that are going
to put him into consideration at a
minimum offensive player of the year may
be the thing that he walks away with but
he still could get mvp yes uh i mean
yeah unlikely but again i think is in
this conversation for sure i mean it's a
team that lost their their franchise
quarterback and that put the more the
focus on him and more of the plays as
far as schematics and the run game and
pass game are
centered around him and he's delivered
and play amazing and of course they're
playing amazing too so it's hard uh not
to pick him here
uh okay i hear you there um i'm gonna
make an i'm gonna make a case or another
guy because like i'm not gonna pick my
homes okay
i'm gonna just throw these you know
jacoby bersette i think i've i've tossed
around his name in my head here uh i i i
also thought about kirk cousins a little
because he's kind of been on fire lately
and i know it doesn't sound cool but i
think ultimately what made me when i
when i stopped i said okay no can't be
kirk cousins gotta go dalvin cook and
i'm gonna go dalvin cook as my last pick
i think he deserves to be in this
conversation first off he's leading the
nfl in rushing he's got 107 more yards
than christian mccaffrey and i know that
mccaffrey had the bye week last week but
just like mccaffrey
and the success the panthers are having
the minnesota vikings are not who they
are unless they have dalvin cook and his
big play explosive ability running the
football and you know mccaffrey gets a
lot of talk about his his dual thread
ability with receiving the catching the
ball too dalvin cook is no sl slouch in
the passing game i mean he's got 20
receptions on the air 24 receptions
excuse me for 220 yards so he's like 115
or 100 yards away and receiving yards
behind a guy like mccaffrey but i think
this is one of the best players in all
of football and
he's certainly in the conversation for
the best running back in football and
really the the center point for a team
that's uh really good in the nfc
well and you know i i you make a great
point because one of the reasons kirk
cousins is playing so well is because
he's setting up that action bootleg to
the left because everybody is obsessed
with stopping dalvin cook exactly and
dalvin cook in that respect has more
value it's just someone else gets the
statistical benefit of the play right
where you don't even touch the ball but
your presence and the fear of what you
could have done with the ball opens up a
70-yard play down the field that's right
that is value yes yes now here's the
thing yes that's going to be lost on the
group of 50 voters and don't get me
started on that but that's going to be
lost on enough of them that he won't get
votes but that is real value here's mine
and let me go behind the curtain and
tell you how this came to be i wrote an
item on monday
trying to exhaust all the potential
candidates leading contenders fringe
candidates in the long shots and i
published it and within five minutes i
heard from someone who is very connected
very in the know and said you left a guy
out that you should have put on there
and you know what i was right i was
wrong i mean and i added the guy after
the fact just a few minutes after the
column went live
there's never been a receiver to win
the mvp award in the history a kicker
has won defensive players have won but
never a receiver and here's why because
the guy throwing the ball to the
receiver is the guy who's going to get
the credit when the receiver has the big
year
this year
michael thomas is having the big year
for new orleans
but there's no one quarterback that's
going to be able to claim credit for it
because it's drew brees then it's teddy
bridgewater then it's going to be drew
brees again and think about this thomas
is leading the league in receptions and
yardage with teddy bridgewater starting
the last five games no knock on teddy
bridgewater but the fact that tom i mean
because when drew brees got hurt it's
like well they wasted all that money on
michael thomas and now they're not gonna
get the most out of him oh they still
have and this saints team you gotta have
somebody on that saints team that stands
out and thomas stands out and look it's
a tough case to make but i think he
needs to be on that list and i think
more people need to be thinking about
michael thomas as an mvp candidate i'm
not going to argue with you there he was
on my list of guys i mean he was a
little farther down but i wrote his name
down i mean i i hear you he's the focal
point of that offense and especially the
drop back pass game i mean everything is
usually designed for michael thomas and
for him to deliver whether it's man or
zone so i think that's one of the unique
things about the mvp thing right now
this year where you got the saints you
know the 49ers and the patriots i think
most people would agree those are the
three best teams in football there's no
they're winning with team you know
there's not that's that clear-cut guy
and michael thomas does deserve to be in
the conversation you're right but i just
think it's a an interesting aspect
that's a little different than years
past
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports